to that point
i i have to take a dig at the new york
times here because i cannot believe them
i
just cannot believe this um zach if you
want to put this up research boosts
evidence of masks utilities
some experts say masks have long been
known to help stop infected people from
spreading the virus
well like months but some research
suggests they
also protect the uninfected and then
there's a bullet point here masks may
also protect people wearing them
some experts say i don't want to get
down
um this you will you'll remember i
went off on a tirade last night when i
saw this i
can not believe the level
of scientific illiteracy and
frankly journalistic fraud in this the
we had the surgeon general and the who
telling us that mass
did no good at all with a respiratory
virus
then they came around and admitted that
that was actually a political move
designed to protect
the the short the the too few masks that
we had
so that health workers could use them
okay
but they insisted that you only wear a
mask to protect others from
you not you from others as if masks are
unidirectional
masks aren't unidirectional in fact
there are some mass through
unidirectional you've all seen these the
little valves in them
they actually allow you to breathe your
viral particles out into the world and
it makes it a little more comfortable to
live inside of them
and they've been banned now at many
hospitals because it's exactly the
opposite of what you're supposed to be
doing but there is no mask
out there that i have ever heard of that
is unidirectional in the other direction
where you are breathing in all of the
particles
and not able to expel them so
the idea that we needed unnamed people
in lab coats
to tell us that masks might actually
both protect
you from others and others from you and
that this is
not even exp accepted enough that we are
being told some experts say it
my [ __ ] god like this this makes me
so mad
of course half the country doesn't want
to wear a mask of course this is
politicized because they are
no one knows how to think scientifically
and they are
appealing to authority for the most
basic fundamental ideas
put something over your mouth and you
won't spread droplets which might have
virus in them
put some something over your mouth and
you won't inhale droplets which might
have virus in them
yep there it is so i would just point
out
i mean it's obviously implicit in what
you're saying here but we nailed this
from the beginning and that's our very
first this is episode one it's episode
one and the point was
what kind of nonsense we are hearing but
obviously
we're dealing with a virus we don't know
what it can do we know it is transmitted
uh through inhaling droplets wear a mask
can't buy a mask make a mask it doesn't
have to be medical in nature bandana
works
just fine and so the point is look all
you have to be able to do is think
clearly
and what does think clearly require of
you well one thing it requires is that
you put politics aside
yes right um you know this is a my god
and a very unfortunate if wonderful
vindication
of the fact that you know common sense
will do it yeah
right common sense is enough just basic
training but
but again and again and again
wearing a mask to protect yourself from
particles
that are in droplets means that when
you're outside away from people you
don't need to wear a mask now could the
virus evolve into something else
yeah but this has become
i've said it over and over and over
again this is star-bellied sneetches and
stages without
if you're wearing a mask you must be one
of us if you're not wearing a mask you
must be one of them
or flip it no you wear a mask when you
need to wear a mask
inside with other people whom you don't
live with all the time
yep the other thing i would point out is
that
if you go back to our earliest live
streams about this
you will find that our model was not
nearly as good that we didn't know
enough about how this thing was
transmitted so we were very concerned
about things that turn out to be very
low likelihood of transmitting it like
um i've still got copper on most of our
external doorknobs right right which is
certainly not going to hurt yeah
right but um but not probably all that
necessary
and the uh you know the simple concern
about surfaces is probably overrated in
the case of this particular virus for
whatever reason could change
it could learn that trick but at the
moment that doesn't seem to be the
priority the priority seems to be
these airborne droplets it does seem to
be an issue
of the volume of the space you are in so
there's some kind of model that we've
developed where
there's a bucket and if you don't reach
the top of the bucket then even if
you're encountering virus
a particle is not going to get you
because your immune system can fend it
off
if you exceed the top of the bucket it
gets you so you want to you know
this then creates the uh you know the
thing i worried about
downtown when we went to the protest was
outdoors high volume but if you were
downwind
of somebody who was sick then you might
fill that bucket up and you might
contract it which i you know i still
don't feel good about
having i think we needed to see the
protest but there's a risk in it that i
think is unacceptable
which is you couldn't control who was up
up
wind of you that's right and there's a
lot of shouting a lot of shouting
exactly which we know to be
particularly bad but in any case i think
that you know the whole thing is an
argument for
don't over complicate this if somebody
is saying nonsense
like masks don't help you avoid this
respiratory virus
they're probably full of [ __ ]
[Music]